[Music]
the vibe is amazing the audience is
gonna be great
it's gonna be such an awesome experience
it really is ain't no party like a
backstreet party and the Backstreet Boys
are bringing the party to Vegas
headlining their larger-than-life
residency show at Planet Hollywood
starting March 1st oh my god went back
to get the band was formed in the early
90s by the late Lou Pearlman whom they
had a tumultuous relationship with
Pearlman died last August while serving
a 25-year prison sentence I mean this
was someone who is responsible for the
birth of this group and for many great
years I was definitely bittersweet for
me and it's sad that it had to end that
way and yeah yeah I thought our
relationship ended the way it did and
that his life in the historians have we
not gone through all the highs and lows
that we've been through as a group or as
individuals we wouldn't be the men that
we are today and we I don't think we'd
still be together but I think about that
and it kind of makes me think about to
how you all have lasted this long
together keeping a friendship together
keeping a group together have you done
idea it's like a man fingers on guys
that work at it yeah it's like a
marriage and like a fan singular
counseling yeah we do what did we do con
things out and our first manager
suggested you guys better get into
therapy now cuz you're gonna need it
later
so money as time goes on the issues
gotta add up you know the things kind of
like you know but it's like a family you
know it's a shame ideally to you to keep
like I know we talked it out we boxed it
out
Oh for ya so y'all get in the throat
come on sometimes you got to
[Music]